about half of Democratic Republic of
Congos nearly 100 million people are
followers of the Roman Catholic Church
the Vatican says it's the largest
Catholic population in Africa
Pope Francis visit to the capital
Kinshasa is expected to draw vast crowds
the fact that the pope is coming to a
troubled country like ours due to war
and other things it's a big risk that he
has decided to take and for us it's a
great joy and it shows his love for us
we're very happy
Catholicism was spread widely here my
missionaries working on the Belgium
colonial rule about 130 years ago the
relationship between the colonial state
and the Catholic church was close since
Independence in the 1960s the Catholic
church has become one of the most
powerful critics of Congo's rulers and
one of the most influential voices
campaigning for democracy
five years ago it was Catholic Bishops
and Priests who led protests calling for
overdue elections to be held
images of police violence in the
churches and Cathedrals Drew
International attention and condemnation
and the delayed polls went ahead Pope
Francis visit comes less than a year
before the next vote is due
president Felix Jessica wants to run for
a second term the opposition and the
Catholic Church have already complained
of irregularities in the electoral
process
armed conflicts have escalated in recent
years the M23 armed group widely
understood to be backed by neighboring
Rwanda has seized swathes of territory
Rwanda denies backing the group
its Advance has forced around half a
million people from their homes on top
of the 5 million already displaced by
conflicts
the Vatican says Pope Francis is
visiting Congo and South Sudan as a
pilgrim of Peace followers are Keen to
see him
I bought this calendar I'm happy to have
the Pope's Effigy at home
it's a great blessing for me and my
children
the Catholic church plays a major role
here providing services that the
government usually does not such as
health care and education
the first papal visit in nearly 40 years
is significant for its tens of millions
of followers Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
Kinshasa Democratic Republic of Congo